عملته مع رئيسين للجمهوريه جاك جاك كان مع
انضمام تركيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي حيث
قال ان تركيا على مفترق طرق بين قارتين
وكان يريد ان يدفع تركيا في اتجاه القيم
الاوروبيه بدلا من ان تتجه شرقا اما
نيكولا ساكوزي فكان يقول ان تركيا هي بلد
كبيره وقيامها مختلفه عن قيامنا وصحيح ان
موقف الرئيس اردوغان كان عاملا مهما لهذا
الرفض لان تركيا تدعو الى نمط حياه يتعارض
مع ذلك السائد في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اجراءات الانضمام كانت بدات وقد حدث تقدم
في بعض المجالات ولكن في الوقت ذاته كان
هناك رفض مطلق للعيش على غرار ما يعيشه
مجمل الاوروبيين انطلاقا من هنا الموقف
الثالث الذي يعمل على التوفيق بين الاثنين
يقول
انا تركيا لا يمكنها حاليا ان تتبنى
الموقف السياسي الاوروبي في المقابل يمكن
ابرام اتفاقات معها في المجال الاقتصادي
وحتى الاجتماعيه وهذا الامر ممكن